[Applaudissements]
moi je suis socialiste et je l'assumé
une leadership européen international et
je le tiens de mon peuple et
je travaille sérieusement trouvent ils
veulent c'est des gens de toute façon là
il y en a certains au lieu 2 le bordel y
feraient mieux d'aller regarder
parce qu'il y en a qui ont des qualités
mais n'y a d'ailleurs pas une culture
française
comment l art français je n'ai jamais je
suis désolé de vous dire on se fout des
programmes ce qui importe c'est la
visible le gaulois réfractaires au
changement
[Musique]
mais je ne ferai rien
ni aux fainéants new cynique mieux
externe
la société gad vous savez 7,7 à baduel
il y a dans cette société une majorité
de femmes il y en a qui sont pour
beaucoup ils les traits pour beaucoup on
leur explique vous n'avez plus de
d'avenir à gad aux alentours aller
travailler à 50 ou 60 km ces gens là
n'ont pas le permis de conduire
rien que ça c'est travailler et negar
c'est un lieu où on croise les gens qui
réussissent et des gens qui ne sont rien
françaises et les français détestent les
réformes
qui décomposent éviter les réformes on
ne les fait pas ça peuple qui détestent
star je ne proposerait pas de modifier
durant le quinquennat à venir l'âge de
départ à la retraite et
l'immigration c'est une chance préoccupé
que ce soit l'immigration c'est une
chance différence entre être beaucoup
plus elle doit faire plus pour en
accueillir el nino ça nous est tous des
constructeurs ou en instaurer pour ma
part j'ai pour ma part beaucoup pour ma
part pour ma part